on the 27th of April the recruitment
mentors podcast will be taking over
Manchester
we're going to be discussing how to win
in 2023.
we're going to be talking about business
development strategies that are working
in the current market we're going to be
finding out people's approach to
building High performing teams we're
going to be finding out people's
perspective on the 360 recruitment model
should we still be expanding in the US
and so much more joining us will be
three fantastic guest speakers who have
all appeared on the podcast and the
Penrose Alex Elliot and Kyle Gallagher
[Music]
cannot wait to see all of you there for
an evening of discussion and networking
with our industry kids we can't wait to
see you all on the 27th